all right listen let's not mince words
elizabeth warren has a totally toxic
surrogate with racist and homophobic
tweets in her past i'm going to talk
about this right now i'm going to give
you the full story but before i get into
that
several dozen of you beautifully nice
people emailed me about this over the
last 24 hours
the gist of the emails was david you
covered Bernie's toxic surrogate Linda
Sarsour but you won't cover Elizabeth
Warren's equally toxic surrogate because
you're a warren chill or an
establishment centrist
or a warren tool or whatever no no no no
no I covered Linda Sarsour because she
is a toxic person and no Democratic
candidate should have someone like her
as a surrogate which Bernie does my
coverage was not partisan it was not for
or against any candidate I want my house
clean no matter who or what we are
talking about in the same way I'd be a
hypocrite
if I didn't cover a toxic Warren
surrogate we need our conscience is
clean we need to clean our houses so
today I'm going to tell you about Ashley
Marie Preston Preston is a Warren
campaign surrogate she has appeared on
many shows as a surrogate including over
with our friends at the Young Turks
she's in a Warren campaign ad that was
released five or six days ago and
Preston has a disgusting Twitter history
of racism and homophobia period I am NOT
going to mitigate it in any way some
items from her past quotes Latino and
Asian businesses need to stop being rude
and effing disrespectful and I know it's
a lot to ask but in California speak
effing English this is the type of thing
we hear all the time from the disgusting
people on the right and we denounce it
and we have to denounce it here the
identity of Ashlee Marie Preston is not
a mitigating factor in that this is
absolutely disgusting depraved speech
another example from a Warren surrogate
Ashlee Marie Preston
quote I love gay men but this county
clerk at window G is an M effing [ __ ]
witted I could go on but I won't now
there are some in the identity politics
sliver of the left who have come to
defend ashley marie preston on the basis
of different identity boxes that she
checks for example Preston his
transgender and thus we need to
understand something about her treatment
by society about her experience that
makes this somehow more ok or not as bad
or as a black person Preston has been
treated so poorly by the way that
society no guys know okay we can't
defend this she has no place in any
Democratic campaign no matter what her
identity is now there are people
choosing to make the story about TYT I
believe TYT has put out a statement the
bottom line is that from what I've seen
if this surrogates appearances on t YT t
uit identified preston as a warren
surrogate when she would comment i don't
know much else about what TYT should be
doing in terms of checking the twitter
histories of everyone my guess is
Preston maybe is not going to be back on
T YT but I could be wrong but the
important thing is that if the argument
is T YT was wrong
to have her on I would want to
understand why because people associated
with campaigns do shows all the time and
as far as I know she was identified as a
surrogate if the argument is T YT was
short-sighted because they didn't do
their due diligence about the things in
Ashley Marie Preston's past okay but
then the campaign who had her as a
surrogate is ten times more wrong for
not doing their due diligence since
there she's actually a surrogate of the
campaign she's just appearing on t YT
but the bottom line is I'm not a
hypocrite Linda Sarsour is toxic and
Bernie should have no affiliation with
her Ashley Marie Preston is toxic and
Warren should have no affiliation with
her there's no place for this okay I got
a few emails from Warren supporters
saying David I think this is
horrible I'm contacting the Warren
campaign and saying Preston must be
removed as a surrogate great I'm an
equal-opportunity person on this I'm not
affiliated with any campaign
Bernie should get rid of Linda Sarsour
as a surrogate Warren should get rid of
Ashley Murray Preston as a surrogate we
shouldn't even be wasting time arguing
about this this is 100 percent cut and
dry there are too many problems that
need to be solved there are too many
issues that need to be discussed we need
to sort out how does Bernie's health
care policy compared to that of
Elizabeth Warren what will each cost how
will each be implemented what will each
cover but all of this stuff right we
can't be distracted with toxic
surrogates with absolutely vile
disgusting homophobic and racist
comments in their Twitter histories this
is a disservice to Elizabeth Warren
Linda Sarsour it does a disservice to
Bernie Sanders they should be gone and
we should be focusing on the issues
period and for everybody who said I
wouldn't talk about this because I'm
some kind of Warren chill I think I'm
being a pretty unequivocal in my
comments here today